boa tarde vive em mais de 10 casas
frequenta e mais de 14 escolas vivia em
cinco cidades aprender todos os dias e
por isso me considero um aprendiz tempo
é fundamental
a história de um super herói e neste
caso esse homem eu super homem o homem
aranha é o homem aranha e o capitão
américa é o capitão está em 1
fui investigar acham os tipos no âmbito
da população e no âmbito da imaginação
porque infelizmente e infelizmente os
super heróis não existem
usar e ver quais são os tipos de
superpoderes que cada super herói da
minha vida procurei encontrar são os
cinco super poderes
o primeiro longe de uma supervisão do
mundo ou criarem uma rede social um
projeto que tem que ter a visão a parede
tem que conseguir ir para lá o quê
a nossa realidade hoje ter uma força
descomunal dias
trabalho trabalho trabalho a trabalho ea
trabalho do trabalho há mais trabalho
em terceiro o melhor no que quer que
seja tem que trabalhar de forma de
trabalho
se eu não quero uma coisa eu não vou
trabalhar para ter um super herói famosa
nunca ser um bom pai um bom e se não
tiverem alegria não forem super
confiante naquilo que nunca serão
a maioria muitas vezes nos dias de hoje
confundimos alegria com dinheiro
dinheiro não é sinônimo de alegria e
estão aqui e ver gráfico representa tudo
o que eu ganhei desde 1994 até os dias
dos santos nandó em 2015
os rendimentos por ano na faculdade não
ganhava nada sozinho
ao contrário dos meus maiores níveis de
alegria e mais confiante quando fui
fazer o que queria fazer como bolsa
transporte público divide a casa com
outras duas pessoas fantásticas todos os
meses para ter a certeza de que não
utilizava de uma forma que não me ajudar
a terminar um mestrado nos estados
unidos e também desempregado já me
aconteceu durante a vossa vida
é terminar a vossa produtiva será o
segundo álbum sex party despedidos duas
ou três vezes encontrar um fracasso em
encontrar uma desilusão a 1
mas nesse momento talvez você encontre a
felicidade e infelicidade foi como
estava desempregado teve tempo e
oportunidade de fazer mais um filtro
extrema
por isso não junta em vosso objetivo é
fazer da pessoa que está aqui
todos vós é que os peço é que encontrei
na vida
a vossa forma de voar que encontrei a
vossa supervisão que fosse encontrar a
vossa força que encontrei voz crer que
encontrei vossa super confiança mas que
acima de tudo
procurei sempre sempre aquilo que é a
felicidade
muito obrigada